that was me my dad traveled for business  and it absolutely I was not in a single  parent home there you go there no I  that's what I'm saying that is still  present even though he's not there  physically no but that's that's why I'm  sorry  it's not the same thing because I know  my mom and my dad were in love and when  I and I got to see my parents be in love  growing up and even when all my friends  came over and they were they were both  together they'd always say your parents  get along better than all the other  parents and I got to grow up seeing my  parents in love I got to see them go on  dates when I was a kid I got to where I  remember we would like cook for them and  do like a date night and like surprise  them and we have these family memories  we're at Christmas like we all do the  same Christmas stockings we have family  traditions that we do every year you  don't get that in a single mother home